Ich sagte nicht:
"So, ab heute bin ich Bestatter."
Ich habe noch keine Ahnung, wie es
läuft, aber ich mache es einfach.
Ich habe mich
lange darauf vorbereitet,
viele Sachen musste ich
selber im Internet herausfinden:
Wie geht das, wie macht man das?
Wie war das konkret, als du
die erste Leiche präpariert hast?
Konkret? Ein spezielles Gefühl.
Man hatte noch nicht oft - eigent-
lich noch nie - mit dem Tod zu tun.
Am Anfang war für mich ein toter
Mensch seltsam, so kalt und ruhig.
Er sieht zwar friedlich aus,
aber es war ein spezielles Gefühl.
Kevin Huguenin ist mit 16
der jüngste Bestatter der Schweiz
und führt bereits
sein eigenes Bestattungsunternehmen.
Kann das gut gehen?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Mit 16 darf Kevin den Leichenwagen
noch nicht selber fahren.
Dafür hat er einen Mitarbeiter.
Sein 30er-Mobil hingegen schon.
In meinem Kopf
die immer wiederkehrende Frage:
Wie kommt ein Teenager auf die Idee,
Bestatter zu werden?
Wegen der Fernsehserie?
Nein, ich bin schon
viel früher auf die Idee gekommen.
Die Serie "Der Bestatter"
gibt es noch nicht so lange.
Ich begann
schon etwa mit zehn Jahren,
mich für diesen Beruf
zu interessieren.
Warum?
Damals kam ich zum ersten Mal
in Kontakt mit dem Tod:
Mein Götti ist damals gestorben.
Dann habe ich gesehen,
wie eine Beerdigung abläuft,
ich habe auch
einen Bestatter gesehen.
Und damals habe ich begonnen,
mich dafür zu interessieren.
Und dann
wurde das Interesse immer stärker.
Er wollte sich bei erfahrenen
Bestattern ausbilden lassen.
Aber er bekam nur Absagen.
Dann machte er sich selbstständig.
Nun hat er
ein Geschäft in Lyss und Biel.
Sein Ziel: neuen Wind
ins Bestatterwesen bringen.
Es soll ja
nicht schwarz und dunkel sein.
Der Tod ist an sich
schon dunkel genug.
Und etwas Helles ist einfach
natürlicher und freundlicher.
Diese Branche basiert auf Tradition.
Alteingesessene
bekommen die Mehrheit der Aufträge.
Kevin hatte dieses Jahr schon elf,
aber seit einem Monat läuft nichts.
Sein Berufsleben besteht zurzeit
aus Warten - warten auf die Toten.
Ich muss das annehmen.
Und ich weiss ...
Ich bin optimistisch, dass
die Aufträge wieder zunehmen werden.
Am Abend ist Kevin bei
seiner Mutter zum Essen eingeladen.
Er wohnt allein,
seit sie vor einem halben Jahr
mit ihrem Partner
zusammengezogen ist.
Hallo.
- Hoi, hattest du einen guten Tag?
Ja.
- Schön.
Es war ruhig.
- War heute nichts los?
Nein. Also, machen wir Abendessen.
Magst du mir helfen,
den Tisch zu decken? - Ja.
Von Anfang an
waren die beiden ein Zweierteam.
Kevin kennt seinen Vater nicht.
Die Berufswahl ihres Sohnes:
für Yolanda Huguenin
anfangs gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Wie kann ein 16-Jähriger
mit dem Ganzen umgehen -
mit der Trauer und den Angehörigen?
Die Leute sterben ja
nicht immer auf eine schöne Art,
da kommen auch andere Sachen. Ihn
interessierte von Anfang an alles.
Da hatte ich
schon so meine Bedenken.
Ich habe alles probiert,
um ihn auf andere Ideen zu bringen.
Aber ich habe festgestellt,
dass das sein Ding ist.
Er will diesen Weg einschlagen
und keinen anderen.
Wenn etwas schiefläuft,
muss sie geradestehen.
Kevin ist nicht mündig
und darum nicht berechtigt,
Geschäfte abzuschliessen.
Die gesamte Verantwortung liegt bei
der Mutter - auch die finanzielle.
Kevin ist mein einziges Kind -
man will alles geben.
Und trotzdem muss man
auch an sich selber denken.
Eigentlich ist es mein Ziel,
voll und ganz hinter ihm zu stehen,
bis er 18 ist, ihn bis dahin
finanziell zu unterstützen.
Aber wie gesagt:
Wenn es nicht läuft ...
Er kann nicht auf einer Bank
einen Kredit aufnehmen.
Dann muss ich halt
weiterhin für ihn geradestehen.
Einfach einmal, bis ich 18 bin.
Wir werden es sehen.
Könnten es
Tausende Franken werden,
oder sagt Mami irgendwann:
"Bis hier und nicht weiter?"
Wenn es
weiterhin so läuft ...
... dann hält es sich
eigentlich im Rahmen.
Es braucht seine Zeit,
das ist mir ganz bewusst.
Wenn man ein Geschäft aufbaut,
spricht man von drei bis fünf Jah-
ren, bis das alles finanziert ist.
Das Auto, die Wohnung, das Lokal.
Es braucht einfach seine Zeit
und so lange stehe ich dahinter.
Und eben nebenbei etwas zu machen,
ist auch sehr schwierig.
Ich habe auch schon
einen Job als Hauswart angefangen,
aber wenn ich einen Auftrag
habe, muss ich dann einfach weg.
Besonders wenn es Spezialereignisse
sind, noch mit der Polizei zusammen,
dann muss ich einfach gehen.
Und das ist
in verschiedenen Berufen schwierig.
Nicht einmal als Hauswart
hat es funktioniert.
Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht, Kevin.
Komm gut nach Hause.
- Danke für das Essen.
Gern geschehen, komm gut nach Hause!
Einen Monat später treffe ich
ihn wieder, im Altersheim Lyss.
Guten Tag, sind Sie Frau Joliat?
- Ja. - Huguenin Kevin, freut mich.
Herr? - Huguenin.
- Freut mich. Herzlich willkommen.
Möchten Sie kurz hineinkommen?
- Gerne, ja.
Darf ich mich kurz hinsetzen?
Danke schön.
Es regnet draussen,
es ist etwas nass geworden.
Ich habe ein paar Flyer mitgebracht.
Mit 15 Jahren?
- Genau.
Da habe ich es gegründet.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
- Danke.
Machen Sie auch Rundumberatungen?
- Genau.
Viele sind ziemlich verzweifelt,
wenn sie sich plötzlich um so viel
Administratives kümmern müssen.
Das würden Sie alles übernehmen?
- Ja, ich mache alles selber.
Wir haben einen liebevollen Umgang
mit den Verstorbenen,
und wir wollen alles ermöglichen.
Wie alt sind Sie jetzt?
Mit 15 haben Sie begonnen.
Ich werde bald 17.
- Super.
Im Moment läuft es nicht so.
Zu Beginn ist es gut angelaufen.
Es ist auch etwas ungewohnt, dass
das eine so junge Person macht.
Klar, es ist auch die Unsicherheit:
Kann er das, wie macht er das?
Dann nehmen sie lieber jenen,
der es seit 50 Jahren macht,
dann wissen sie, dass er es kann.
Es ist eher die Angst.
Ich glaube, Sie haben schon recht,
wenn Sie sagen,
dass die Leute
eine erfahrene Person wünschen.
Denn in einer solchen Situation
braucht man viel Sicherheit.
In einer solchen Situation
braucht man tiefgründige Gespräche,
Trauerbegleitung, Verständnis.
Das traut man Ihnen nicht unbedingt
zu, wenn man Sie nicht kennt.
Das muss man selber herausfinden.
Okay, also.
Besten Dank für Ihre Zeit,
die Sie geopfert haben.
Das ist gern geschehen, ich
unterstütze Sie gern, wenn es geht.
Das ist sehr nett.
Gut, besten Dank, Frau Joliat.
Vielleicht bis ein anderes Mal und
besten Dank für die geopferte Zeit.
Puh.
Bist du zufrieden?
- Ja, ich bin zufrieden.
Und gespannt,
ob das hier etwas wird.
Ob die zukünftigen Kunden,
die Angehörigen,
mich annehmen würden oder nicht.
Aber ich bin überzeugt,
dass sie mich empfehlen werden.
Warum?
Ich habe einen seriösen Eindruck,
es ist ein seriöses Altersheim,
die Dame wirkte seriös und ich
glaube, sie macht, was sie sagt.
Im Krematorium Bern treffe ich
einen Bestatter mit Erfahrung.
Daniel Meyer. Er arbeitet bei
verschiedenen Bestattungsunternehmen.
Auch bei Kevin Huguenin.
Der junge Mann lebt das,
er träumt davon.
Er ist nicht eine Person für
eine Arbeit, die um 8 Uhr beginnt,
und um 17 Uhr endet,
sondern er ist immer Bestatter.
Und das schon seit so jung, als
ich noch nicht einmal daran dachte,
und ins Poesiealbum schrieb,
dass ich Fussballer werden möchte.
Der Vorsprung, den er dadurch hat,
macht ihn
auch etwas reifer und erfahrener.
Aber je mehr Aufträge
man miteinander erlebt,
desto mehr praktische Erfahrungen
kommen dazu.
Aber das heisst nicht,
dass man grundsätzlich schlecht ist,
wenn man die nicht hat.
Denn sonst könnte kein anderer
Bestatter anfangen zu arbeiten.
Es gehört genau das dazu,
was ich z.T. bei anderen
jungen Menschen vermisse:
die Motivation,
einfach etwas zu machen.
Und das mit Leib und Seele,
also wirklich mit Herz.
Das spürt man bei Kevin,
und das motiviert mich auch,
mit ihm zusammenzuarbeiten: zu
wissen, dass er das wirklich will.
Kevin hat es nicht leicht, sich
im Bestatter-Business zu etablieren -
besonders, wenn ihm zusätzlich noch
Kollegen das Leben schwer machen.
Am Montag kam um 20 Uhr ein Anruf,
es ginge um einen Todesfall,
ich solle doch eine Offerte machen.
Doch dann stellte sich heraus,
dass das eine Verarschung war.
Die Nummer existierte nicht,
es nahm niemand ab.
Schade.
- Wie ist das für dich?
Dass man mich verarschte? Blöd.
Aber es war zu einer guten Zeit: Um
20 Uhr ist man noch nicht im Bett.
Aber so wie die letzten Male,
als es um 2 oder 3 Uhr nachts war,
dann ist es schon blöder,
in diesem Zeitraum.
Gegen Widerstände zu kämpfen:
für Kevin nichts Neues.
Er war schon in der Schule
ein Aussenseiter.
In der fünften Primarklasse
entschied seine Mutter,
dass er auf eine antiautoritäre
Privatschule wechseln solle,
da er gemobbt wurde.
Es war sicher nicht einfach,
aber ich habe mich dagegen gewehrt.
Ich habe nicht gesagt,
dass das stimmt.
Um mir wehzutun, braucht es viel.
Was tut denn richtig weh?
Das hat es bisher
noch nicht gegeben.
Ich habe eine ganz starke Psyche
und ich kann mich auch wehren.
Du hast noch nie etwas erlebt,
das dir wehtat?
Nein.
Jetzt für das Berufsleben
ist es sicher ein Vorteil,
solche Sachen erlebt zu haben.
In meinem jetzigen Berufsleben
muss ich mich auch wehren können.
Also siehst du Parallelen
zwischen der Mobbingzeit und jetzt?
Ja, Parallelen gibt es.
Es wiederholt sich alles
immer wieder ein bisschen.
Ich war schon immer alleine,
ich bin wirklich ein Einzelgänger.
Ich habe auch eine Einzelfirma,
ich wohne auch alleine.
Es hat schon eher diesen Sinn,
ich bin auch ein Einzelkämpfer.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Ich bin irritiert
und beeindruckt zugleich,
wie unbeirrt Kevin seinen Weg geht.
Wieder einmal nichts.
Mit stoischer Ruhe.
Scheinbar gegen alle Widrigkeiten.
Um sein Einzugsgebiet zu erweitern,
wird er
eine weitere Filiale eröffnen -
in Grafenried, einem Berner Vorort.
Warum halst er sich
bei der aktuellen Auftragsflaute
noch mehr Fixkosten auf?
Das ist natürlich
in den Kosten schon einberechnet.
Es geht auf.
Diese Räumlichkeiten
sind auch wie Werbung.
Und ich denke,
dass es etwas bringen wird,
wenn man wieder ein Gebiet mehr hat.
Das kann man nicht nur
durch Internetwerbung machen.
Denn so ist man trotzdem vor Ort.
Was ich vorhabe, ist,
erfolgreich zu werden.
Das ist dein grösster Traum?
- Ja.
Ja, sonst würde man
so etwas nicht machen.
Ja, ich möchte erfolgreich werden.
Das ist schon ein Traum.
Allen jenen Konkurrenten,
die es mir schwer machen,
all jenen will ich zeigen,
dass es geht.
Und auch all jenen, die sagten,
dass ich noch zu jung sei usw.
Denen zu zeigen, dass nicht
immer nur sie die Platzhirsche sind,
das ist schon noch ein Traum.
Heute Abend könnte er
diese Platzhirsche treffen -
beim jährlichen Bestatteressen
des Krematoriums Bern.
Ob das eine gute Idee ist,
da hinzugehen?
Ich will auch einmal mit anderen,
mit Guten, ins Gespräch kommen.
Das möchte ich sicher.
Das sind interessante Leute.
Aber ich gehe nicht,
um die Konfrontation zu suchen.
Das nicht. Ich hoffe eher,
dass diese eben nicht kommen.
Warum?
- Wieso ich das hoffe?
Weil das recht Probleme geben
könnte, so wie ich manche kenne.
Die könnten schon schwierig tun.
Aber eben:
Ich nehme es, wie es kommt.
Begleitet wird er an diesem Abend
von seinem Mitarbeiter Daniel Meyer.
Huguenin. Freut mich.
Ciao, Silvana.
- Hoi Kevin, schön, dass du da bist.
Guten Abend, Huguenin.
Das Krematorium der Stadt Bern
ist das einzige in der Region,
das Huguenin überhaupt erlaubt,
Verstorbene anzuliefern.
Für die anderen ist er zu jung
und zu wenig vertrauenswürdig.
Ich erlebe Kevin als seriösen
und empathischen jungen Mann.
Ich habe auch Gespräche
mit anderen Bestattern geführt,
die auch schon als jung
in diese Bestatterszene
eingestiegen sind.
Bei uns im Krematorium
haben wir Regeln.
Jeder Bestatter ist
bei uns grundsätzlich willkommen.
Diese Regeln
müssen eingehalten werden.
Und bisher hatten wir
eigentlich keine Probleme.
Wie alt bist du?
- Ich werde bald 17.
Was hast du gelernt?
- Nichts.
Ich bin gleich
in dieses Geschäft rein. - Wie?
Ich habe nichts gelernt, ich stieg
gleich in dieses Business ein.
Aha. Willst du nicht
zuerst noch etwas anderes machen?
Nein, das ist das,
was ich machen möchte.
Ja, ja, aber
irgendwie noch das KV oder so ...
Jetzt eröffne ich noch
eine weitere Filiale in Grafenried.
So einen kleinen Laden.
- Ah, ja.
Die gefürchtete Konkurrenz
ist nicht gekommen.
Du bist der jüngste Bestatter
der Schweiz? - Der Schweiz, ja.
Eine Freundin hast du auch?
- Noch nicht.
20 Jährchen jünger als wir.
Ja, ja.
Es war ein guter Abend.
Ich hatte gute Gesprächspartner.
Für mich war es ein lustiger Abend.
Ja.
Seit knapp drei Monaten
wartet er auf den erlösenden Anruf.
Ich warte natürlich
ständig auf einen Auftrag.
Und ich freue mich umso mehr,
wenn ich wieder etwas arbeiten kann.
Bist du ein grenzenloser Optimist,
dass alles gut kommt?
Man muss etwas optimistisch sein,
sonst hätte man
schon längst aufgegeben.
* Mysteriöse Klänge *
So unerwartet wie der Tod
kommt der langersehnte Auftrag.
Die Polizei Biel
hat Kevin aufgeboten.
Grüezi, Huguenin.
Perfekt.
Ein Mann
wurde tot in seiner Wohnung gefunden.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist bereits klar:
Er starb eines natürlichen Todes.
Darum
kann die Leiche abgeholt werden.
Kann man hineinfahren?
- Warte!
Hier sind die Füsse.
Ich bin froh, wenn ihr helft.
Jetzt muss ich schauen,
dass ich nicht ins Zeug hineinlaufe.
Ist es so gut?
- Ja.
Ob er diesen Auftrag weitermachen
kann, entscheiden die Angehörigen.
Die sind in dieser Nacht
nicht erreichbar.
Darum wird der Tote
erst einmal im Krematorium gekühlt.
Am nächsten Morgen steht fest:
Kevin Huguenin hat den Auftrag.
Er macht sich mit seinem Mitarbeiter
Daniel Meyer auf den Weg ...
Kevin.
- Ciao, Daniel.
... zur Schwester des Verstorbenen
nach Biel.
Ich habe das Gespräch
Daniel in Auftrag gegeben,
weil er
fliessend Französisch spricht.
Ich wüsste gerade das Wort für Sarg:
cercueil.
Aber ich kann es einfach zu wenig,
um die Trauernden kompetent
beraten zu können. Er kann das.
Deshalb habe ich das ihm gegeben.
Bis später, tschüss.
Huguenin ist vielleicht jung,
aber weise genug,
seine Grenzen zu erkennen.
Wo seine Erfahrung aufhört,
setzt er auf die Kompetenz von Meyer.
Ist es gut gegangen?
- Ja, ruckzuck.
Was Kevin Huguenin
genau an diesem Beruf fasziniert,
ist mir
immer noch nicht wirklich klar.
Aber ich sehe einen jungen Mann, der
mit Leib und Seele bei der Sache ist.
Du kannst gleich weiterfahren.
- Ja.
Man kann ihn etwas hochnehmen,
und zwar musst du hier
unter dem Arm noch etwas anheben.
Das ist die klassische Form
des Aufbahrens.
Nimmst du es sehr genau, Kevin?
- Ja.
Wenn es noch eine Aufbahrung gibt,
muss einfach alles stimmen.
Mir ist es wichtig, dass die
Verstorbenen gepflegt gehen können.
So, wie sie ...
So, wie sie waren,
als sie noch lebten.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Jetzt kämme ich die Frisur noch
einmal durch und mache ihn schön.
Das ist für mich eine Ehre,
das noch einmal machen zu dürfen.
Während andere in seinem Alter
noch auf das richtige Leben warten,
ist Kevin Huguenin schon mitten drin.
Und wartet auf die Toten.